all right josh
josh uh where'd you grow up where are
you from central florida
it's a little uh old town called d-berry
and tell me about how you grew up you
had both your parents
when you're young uh
for a little while and then and then at
about uh 11 years old
uh i would say um that one brother and
were two years apart and said nine
i was 11 and uh my parents divorced then
um that uh
we had a little bit of a different
situation i guess the most because it's
pretty common that
you know um kids always go with
the mother um but
that that didn't happen that wasn't our
case so we actually
we went um and stayed with our father
and um
and that caused a lot of kind of like i
don't know i mean i was 11 obviously so
i was you know naive and confused
and about um you know uh
i i just thought my mom was was leaving
us abandoned i
blamed her like you know i was like why
are you doing this to us why would you
why would you do this you know and um
it uh it made me pretty upset uh
for a while uh for sure um
it also you know seeing
when you see other people come into your
parents lives
as um you know new spouses and stuff
it you you have a hard time accepting
that
you know because in the back your head
really you always
you know are you have that little
glimpse of hope that maybe they'll get
back together or something like that
um but you know that wasn't really the
case so
um they both
remarried eventually and stuff and this
kind of i feel like
i was very i was raised very you know
anti-drug uh you know race southern
baptist christian
and so it was like you know school god
all that stuff and
and i feel like and that also too um
my parents actually we they took me to a
doctor and was prescribed that uh
it was diagnosed adhd and so they like
prescribed me ritalin and this was the
first time my
drugs were introduced into my life um
what's funny is like i i hated it like i
would
constantly be asking my parents um
to be off of it i didn't want to take it
i had to take a pill in the morning
at lunch break at school i had to go and
take another pill
and then a pill uh in the afternoon when
i got home
but this was something that like i
didn't want to do at all
um and i just i felt like it
it just didn't feel right i didn't feel
like myself
and uh i was constantly trying to get
off of it and wanting to not be on it
but my parents made me take it and then
this was
also the first time that i ever had
somebody
come to me to try to buy
my my my drugs my pills you know and
that really is threw me off i was like
so i was like why the hell would you
want these i was like i'm trying to not
take them so it's like you want to pay
me for this
so um i feel like that was almost
probably like a passive thing that i
threw in the back of my head
um which led to like
my times of selling a lot of drugs
um but uh
after high school and um
everything kind of just went like you
know kind of fast forward times 100 i
mean
i shortly from 18
to
21 but i was 21 years old i was selling
probably about 15 pounds of weed a week
and um you know and uh being from
florida
uh this is where a lot of people know
the the pill boom happened
um you know you had uh
all these dirty doctors popping up you
know so everybody was kind of
essentially almost made you like this
legal drug dealer
because we're all going around with the
same prescription
you know i all had 240 perc 30s oxy 30s
160 oxy 15s which made no sense
same pill just different dosage and 90s
annex bars
and everyone was doing the same thing
we'd get them
and you know we're paying 50 cents to a
dollar tops a pill
to the pharmacies and then we're hopping
on planes
you know going up north to everyone
knows somebody in new york or boston or
somewhere in the northeast
and as soon as you took them up there
those people are paying a dollar a
milligram
so we're getting the pills for a dollar
and we're selling them for 30 dollars a
pill
so essentially you're just going up
there you fly
up and then you fly back down with a
stack that's
big enough to beat a baby seal to death
with
um you know that uh
really is when things definitely in my
life
it's it got a lot more uh a lot more
hardcore i could say um
nobody knew nobody knew about uh
addiction or nobody knew about like that
we were gonna be hooked
nobody knew about withdrawals nobody
knew about any of that [ __ ]
we just knew that you know you smashed
up at 30 and you sniffed it
and uh you felt great you wanted to
clean your house you had all this energy
you know you [ __ ] for a long time like
everything was awesome
you know so um until the one day came
along that maybe you didn't have any on
your something then you're like
oh my god i feel like [ __ ]
and um that
was definitely the the start of my
battle with opiate addiction and that
i've gone through my life
uh all the way to this day and um
you know it's it's kind of been it's
it's been hard because like i
always uh my family always knows
when something's up because i've always
been on two extremes
in my life which is like i love working
out i love the gym
i love being like physically fit and
just that whole lifestyle
and i always like that extra pep in my
step and everything
so like uh i a lot of times we get
testosterone and you know
which is you know steroids whatever you
want to call it like um
and um would normally take a little bit
of testosterone and everything every
time i'm working out so
which if um you see
you can see some of the pictures on like
uh somebody
like on my instagram or some instagram
name is you know jack
the ripper and uh like there's some
pictures of me on there and i
look like a goddamn gorilla you know um
so and then you know and then when i'm
start partying a little bit or you know
and kind of go to that extreme
i'm just shrivel up obviously because
i'm not working out i'm doing drugs and
i'm you know not taking care of my body
so uh my family always knows there's no
hiding it they're like oh he's doing
good because he's huge and jacked right
now
or he's doing awful because he's you
know
lean and small or whatever
that's kind of how it's i guess been
a lot of times for the most part um
it seems like it's always been i mean
it's never something i i never
want to make sure people get high and
you want to get high and like you like
the feeling or everyone gets attached to
a particular
uh thing about their doc their drug of
choice
that maybe makes them forget or
not think about you know stuff or forget
things
or i kind of feel like i
would always try to run from my
addiction a lot
i found myself moving you know what i
mean i
have lived in pennsylvania i lived in
pittsburgh for
seven years and i loved pittsburgh i've
bartended for 10 years
um uh i make damn good drinks and i'm a
social person i love talking to people
and you know
making people laugh um
but it uh
is one thing is very true that you're
taught is you can never run from an
addiction
like it's always gonna catch up to you
you might escape for a little bit but
it'll get to you eventually like
wherever you are no matter what
it's inevitable like you all know what
i'm talking about especially addicts out
there
people who do drugs you know what i mean
you know you're going to find it if you
really want it you're going to find it
you're going to find some form of it and
you're going to get it
that's just how it is um but you know i
i definitely love the
travels i've been through and different
experiences in my life because i've
gone from a great you know bartending in
awesome locations and places and
uh after hours clubs and i've even
been a a male stripper at a strip club
uh
three-story strip club for women um that
was a pretty entertaining time
uh my stage name was actually gavin
hammer
that's pretty funny but uh
how did you do that what's that how long
did you did you do that
uh it was uh it was for like a year
yeah it was um so you were working out
then yeah
yeah it was it was the best workout
motivation in the world because every
single
weekend i knew you know like that i was
like all right i'm going to be
close to completely naked on a stage in
front of
a bunch of women so um i'll tell you
what that's
really good gym motivation um yeah i did
do um
it was interesting too because so me and
my brother
uh actually were both uh both did he did
a
a dirty dancing routine we called it the
crazy swayze
and uh and i did a um country boy
routine uh
and um but it was every friday and
saturday night
that we had to do that that we we
stripped
and um and you know did our routines and
stuff and so
we all we were bartenders so we never
we always had scheduled off from
bartending friday and saturday so all
our co-workers
you know we lived uh in a very uh
rich like yuppity town or uppity town in
um
right outside of downtown pittsburgh
called swickley
and this is where like the athletes live
the ceos all these people
and so we knew a lot of you know
uh upper families upper class families
and
and
all these people and so they couldn't
know that about us you know i mean so
if everyone was very confused of why we
never wanted to buy you know friday and
saturday night in the bartending
industry
you want to always work those nights is
the biggest money nights
but we never wanted to work those nights
because we couldn't we were off
you know taking our clothes off for uh
women i remember i used to have this
regular
this one was a surgeon from west
virginia
and um she's put 50s in my underwear she
was she was great
but uh that was um you know pretty wild
um uh yeah i've had um
you know in the end
even when you think you have a wrap on
things and you're doing
you know and you're successful and
you're making i mean when i was selling
15 pounds of weed a week and
you know making 2 500 30 grand every
week
and to date the most ever made in one
day in four hours i made 2
750 and that was a really good day
um but you know and i'm making all that
money
but then i'm buying bricks of heroin and
um you know and shooting heroin every
day
and i think a lot of this you know i
i always wonder to myself i guess if uh
if i never would have took ritalin or
like never would have started like
introducing things like that in my life
would i have ever done that
or would i revenge of that like i
remember the time where i like said
i would never ever ever touch needles
like i would never put a needle in my
arm and
one of my best friends uh still to this
day
um not a very best friend move but you
know i was
not feeling well a little dope sick that
day and uh
i called my buddy and you know i was
like yeah i needed something
and um a lot some of you will be
familiar with this pill it's called the
delada
the lotta d8 and uh the d
and um
that pill is meant to be iv'd
it's if you sniff it or if you eat it or
anything like that
it's just and it's not the same you know
i mean it just doesn't really do [ __ ]
really basically
but if you bang that thing uh it is um
you just feel like just the heat wave
start from your toes to the top of your
head
to the tip of your dick to like just you
melt and um he told me he was like i'd
say what i got some dilemmas on me and
he's like i'll go ahead and
i'll give you one for free and he's like
but you gotta shoot it
and he's like but you don't have to do
anything you can just put your arm out
do it for you
and that was i don't remember those it
was actually
in the drive in his car in the driveway
at my mom's house
um when i was
i want to say 23 24 i think
23 i think yeah and that was the uh that
was the first time i ever put a needle
in my arm
and um you know
it was really shitty it's caused me um
to lose a lot of things in my life that
i've
that i've really really cared about
uh a lot
um
i'm uh i turned to 35 about a week ago
june 3rd 1986. do you have kids
no i don't i don't have no kids um
you had relationships that love
yeah yeah i've i've had some
amazing um i've had some truly amazing
women in my life
and um amazing beautiful women
uh you know joanna stephanie
jessica and uh a lot of beautiful women
in my life i'd say i'm tempted to say
your full name so people can creep on
you but
just you know talk about but um women
that i
have truly because i've since i was
young
um my parents always thought it was
funny but i always knew
that the two happiest days of my life
would be the day
i'd get married and see a woman walking
down that aisle to me
in the day that i become a father and
unfortunately i've
had neither of those and um
and that's been uh that's been my own
fault you know
every time because i've had amazing
women in my life that
i would have loved to have that with
and in the end i've ended up slipping up
and
and choosing
choosing uh my addiction over them
most recently jessica
was an amazing woman i'll never forget
thank you um
the uh
the day she met when i first moved here
to california
and uh the first job i found was for a
dispensary
and i was holding the weed sign uh
with the green cross on and stuff for a
new dispensary to open
and she drove by and she turned around
and came back and uh
and she she came up and she goes hey uh
you come here often and uh and i'm
thinking to myself uh
what a stupid question you know what i
mean like obviously i'm working
something i'm like oh
she's hitting on me and i'm like and
then um
you know i was like what are you into
and long story short
we um we uh
spent um we hung out that that night
that was july 3rd
actually and then um the next day july
4th we got together again
and uh we got actually uh and got a
got a hotel room and didn't see one
firework outside
that night um it was great but um
and we were together um until a couple
months ago
because um
because i chose something else instead
of her essentially
that's the honest truth and um
it's not a choice though is it
it is a choice i don't know i don't know
i don't know if i believe
in the whole
disease thing i don't i don't i take
responsibility um
no one's holding the gun to my head when
i
sniff that line or
i mean the first time you tried it was a
choice
but then quickly the addiction kicks in
doesn't it and it's it's
beyond your control
from what it's right here yeah yeah it
gets
it gets really hard
to control and uh
there's a lot of days
you just sit there and you just like
you're like [ __ ] like you just wish
it would all be over
you know and i feel awful for
all the wrong and i've done
to all the people
that i truly love and care about
my family and until recently i didn't
talk to
i talked to my father all the time i
love my dad so much
and a few months ago my phone
was stolen again what a [ __ ] shocker
you all know about that [ __ ]
in the world of drugs because you get
high and you [ __ ]
fall asleep or pass out or nod
and uh your [ __ ] gets taken i lost a tab
on
three phones inside of 45 days
all with service and everything and
i lost that phone it was just like oh
[ __ ] it and just didn't talk to my dad
for almost three months
and like that's so [ __ ] up
like
like my poor dad
i'm sh was worried sick you know
thinking his son is dead or
who knows because he knows the addiction
i battle
and that she's so [ __ ] selfish
yes i want nothing more than just be
all behind you it gets all behind you i
was doing good
and then i went on a hiking trip in the
sierra mountains of healthy strong
there's a picture of my thing and being
like
up there in the mountains and doing
grade and then i
was on one rock and i'd had to hop down
about seven feet
down to another rock and i on the
landing i broke my left heel bone in
four places
about a year and a half ago and so i
went to the hospital and
after i made it off the mountain took
hours crawled and
[ __ ] two other hikers helped me
thank god they were good guys you know
arm around each of them and i just
hopped and hopped and
until i finally got into the they laid
me in the bed of a truck and then
took me the rest of the way to get to a
hospital and then
they shot me up with the lot as soon as
they saw my injury and everything and
then it was
all over from there back
back on the trail and uh
you think you have a grasp on in the
beginning you know you think you're
strong enough to go ahead and just
handle it like you maybe dabble you do a
little bit here and there and then
days go by and you don't do anything and
and then uh and
but you know we all know the reality it
just
it's with everything it doesn't matter
whether it's [ __ ]
coffee or drugs or anything
our bodies are designed and built in
this way that
we naturally build tolerances to
anything it's just how it goes you know
dad used to drink two pots of coffee
every damn morning
you know you know some people think holy
[ __ ] how the hell was he not just like
you know what i mean like all over the
place you know me
well that was nothing to my dad because
he drank more and more coffee as the
years went by you know so
in the beginning when you're only doing
a dime heroin
it may start like that and then
as time progresses the inevitable will
happen
i don't care whoever's watching this too
like i don't care like how much you
think you have a grasp on your addiction
or
whatever you you think you got a handle
on it
there is no handle on it it is a
beast that controls you
you do not control it and not at any
point
and you never [ __ ] will so
you you can't win with that demon like
so don't even try like we all go ahead
and try to convince ourselves that we
can dabble and stuff and everything but
i party one small idea yeah
well but uh
my plan is to go to detox very
soon here so today you're living where
uh i don't have a place right now i um
i did i had a i was homeless and i lived
i mean i'm homeless you know so i mean i
i
had a spot in uh
um echo park originally is where i was
and uh
then um they shut echo park down they
actually
came at one o'clock in the morning and
it was three
uh chevy silverados four
or four door eight foot bed with the
rails around the bed and there was
riot officers all around the beds
three of those came in along with the
whole another vehicles
a couple of the vehicles the fence crew
and everything and
at one o'clock in the morning echo park
and then just
like a pit crew in nascar was just ding
ding ding ding
setting up the fence around echo park
and i actually was coming back to the
park
right when they put the first post in
for the fence and i was like what's
going on there's sheriff's everywhere
and uh i said you can't come in
and uh you know i was like well
my stuff's in there i know i have a i'm
homeless my tent's in there and
everything
and they say okay well you can go in
but once you leave you can't come back
in
and no one else is allowed in so it was
really really eerie and weird for
because i guess i i lasted like two days
i was there for like two more days and
stuff
i mean they fenced off the whole entire
park the rules were
no one could leave or no sorry if you
left you couldn't come back in
so once you left that was it and
nobody could come in no one could bring
us supplies or anything at all
there were police officers every it was
like 50 feet
uh like around the whole entire park
so it was like you couldn't if they saw
somebody like
approaching the fence uh they would you
know
they would see it and they would yeah
you couldn't do anything so it's natural
like you know to drown over now because
what's gonna happen if you were gonna
run out of their drugs
no dealers can get in or no food or no
nothing you know what i mean like so
just a matter of time
you know it suffocated this out you know
and um it's pieces of [ __ ] they [ __ ]
lied to and like they
they were going around they had a group
of people associated with a couple of
the different organizations i think
path and like some other one or
something and
they're trying to give us all housing
and everything
and like or what they call housing you
know but the
different shelters and different things
and stuff and
and i told them they came around to me
and i was like all right
he said uh you know we i said
i've heard that the grand you know it's
a housing place downtown
l.a um i've heard it's
as decent and like i know some other
people that got in there and stuff and
they said okay well
um i'll uh i'll go
if you can go ahead and put me in the
grand and um
give me a room there and uh he said and
the lady said
say yeah oh yeah sure i got you no
problem
and you were allowed to pack two bags
so i
you know what my two bags were this just
give you an idea of where my life is
it was especially right then and there
my two bags were one was my clothes and
essential stuff like that
and the other bag was a bag of recycle
recyclables like
that's what was one of my two bags and
then when i got
out the pieces of [ __ ]
lied and as soon as i got out
i stepped out and they could close it
behind me
they said i asked they said okay and
they took a little bit of my information
and she goes
all right just wait a minute they'll
talk to you when they figure out where
they're gonna put you and i said
well they said that lady right over
there said she's they're gonna put me in
the grand
and and then she goes
uh the grant oh oh well no we don't have
any more room in the grand i mean
and so they manipulated they were found
out doing this to a lot of people
and lied to get me out so
i had left behind my tent
my sleeping bag all my things
that were really important and essential
for me to like survive out here
i had lost and had nothing
but a [ __ ] suitcase with some clothes
on
in it and like some toiletries
things like that that was it
and they [ __ ] me like
oh i remember like just
it just reaming out this
twig like this is
this tall skinny ass dude with a
[ __ ] googly eye i wanted i was
yelling at him and ran out so bad i was
like dude i could hit you so hard and
knock your eyes straight
you [ __ ] oh man i remember that and
the car was so many cops and they were
just getting closer and closer and
closer
all surrounded me because they saw me
like i'm yelling i'm screwing this guy
and i thought i was gonna
you know rip his [ __ ] head off which
i wanted to
he was the supervisor and everything but
um
i told him to i was like you know i'd
snap you like a twig
so fast before these cops even got their
hands on me and
when i really said that to him he was
really [ __ ] [ __ ] bricks
but um so too so today you're on skid
row
but today um skid row yeah do you have a
tent or
um i uh like have a
a friend of mine has one and i kind of
you know shares to hang out with him and
stuff and he's a good dude good friend
and how do you get your money
ah gotta hustle gotta hustle
you know that's how it is you gotta
uh
make moves it's a import export business
right
[Music]
yeah do you see hope of getting off the
streets
getting away from fentanyl um
yeah yeah i do that's what i want to do
i
my plan is uh is the tried i've been
trying to i haven't had i had one point
edd and stuff and
i haven't had unemployment or anything
since december
of last year and um
because and i've been trying to get
my you know i have a driver's license
but you know
waltz and everything gets stolen all the
damn time so
and i've been trying to get my fix i
haven't gotten one stimulus check
i've been trying to do that and
everything and i'm so sick and
[ __ ] tired of hearing everybody say
oh it's so simple you just go on and do
the thing
well it's not simple for me apparently
and it doesn't
like i can't just go on and do the thing
or whatever i've
done it and it doesn't work so i don't
you know and i don't know i'm not uh
some tax attorney and i'm not i don't
know all this stuff so
i'm not as tech savvy with that so
financially has been a little rough but
and
just hustling my dick in the dirt trying
to
trying to survive and you know when you
uh
trying to feed an addiction and feed
yourself
and go work out and do all
and just have somewhat of an
existence a happy existence in a life uh
it's it's hard but i do see a hope in
the end because
because in the end i do believe in god
and i i know he's there and i know
and now he loves me and i know uh
i have faith in him and i have faith
that it's gonna be okay
i'm gonna go to detox and i'm gonna get
clean
and i'm gonna get away i need to get
away
i need to hello it goes back to the
running away and i'm not saying run away
and i've met some amazing
people here in l.a this is where my
parents are from
you know my parents are from downey and
uh
i would love to come back here and you
know that uh
you need a detox and i need to
align my spirit and my soul and
get clean and get my body healthy and
right
and i see that happening sooner than
later
excellent it'd be great to see
yeah all right josh well thank you so
much for sharing your story
thanks for the opportunity i wish you
the best thank you i really really hope
uh
i hope this helps some people out there
bless you all sure well thank you man
thanks